salut Thomas je me demandais comment tu
vas aux toilettes dans l'ISS et après ça
va où est-ce que genre tout pars dans
l'espace non tu pars pas dans l'espace
non en fait ça marche par aspiration tu
as un espèce de tuyau avec une un
anentau noir au bout tu branches une
dépression qui se crée tu fais pipi
dedans et ça se ça se recycle et comme
disait mon collègue américain le café du
jour devient le café du lendemain
c'est une manière jolie de le dire tu
vois c'est une belle faç c'est une façon
de dire et pour le reste pour la partie
plutôt solide on va dire là on a on a
rien à faire tout un système pour que ça
soit un peu cont mais en gros on le
stock et puis on le met dans nos
véhicules cargo tu sais quand ils vont
brûler dans l'atmosphère avec nos déchet
en fait c'est comme ça qu'on fait c'est
comme ça qu'on gère mais il y a rien qui
va dans l'espace